yo we gotta play there my love to  console mission vocals on your team if  any six-foot-six the round mound of  rebound  Charles boxes job after score less  fortunate college kids there if you're  not careful he'll pick your pocket duck  love Gary hate her he's a cheeseburger  in her pocket his game is magic its  Penny Hardaway say hello to my little  friend  poet our gold medalist Lisa Leslie don't  forget about the three MVPs one of the  best to ever lace them up Scottie Pippen  hi boys  so we came out of nowhere to win this  tourney and if we win this game we'll go  down at legend any vision dime now we're  eating that junk out of the palm over  here who loves you baby gotta win this  championship  [Music]  my gang do we talk my mouth do too well  really called fire happens all the time  when you're a legend you'll get there  one day check ball ball ball ball